à chenôve 14 mille habitants l'unique
commissariat de la ville se situe au
coeur de la cité il y a quinze ans 30
policiers étaient mobilisés
aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus que quatre
pour lutter contre la délinquance ce
sont des policiers d'autres secteurs qui
interviennent certains riverains
regrettent la police de proximité
supprimée en 2002 on les vend moins
quand même les policiers aussi enlèvera
beaucoup moins il s'en prit part dans
les endroits vraiment que c'est que
c'est fort et tout ça on les voit pas
trop ben oui parce qu'il ya des fois
j'en aurais bien quand même hein comme
d'autres communes chenôve était
candidate pour expérimenter la police de
sécurité du quotidien promise par
emmanuel macron il ya un an
un dispositif censé rapprocher des
forces de l'ordre de la population comme
l'a rappelé le ministre
c'est un dispositif qui apporte une
meilleure utilisation de nos effectifs
donc une meilleure visibilité sur le
terrain donc les effectifs qui sont
présent disponibles et qui bâtissent qui
construisent des partenariats avec les
autres acteurs de la sécurité
mais pour les syndicats de police les
missions sont encore floues et le manque
de moyens criant sur l'agglomération de
dijon pour nous enfin syndicat de police
alliance nationale on trouve que c'est
de la poudre aux yeux il nous manque à
peu près une cinquantaine de policiers
sur dijon 50 policiers sur dijon c'est
des contacts humains c'est de la parole
c'est de l'écouter c'est de l' échange
avec la population et ça aujourd'hui on
l'a pu une police de sécurité du
quotidien qui va continuer d'être
déployés d'ici la fin du quinquennat
une soixantaine de quartier devraient
être concernés